Let's not pretend
that you're
not something you do or should see often.
But that was part of the issue,
according to
these men here
who died today, or Wagner PMC.
Their blood is still fresh.
Perhaps Russia's most prominent military
figure,
Yevgeny Prigozhin,
had a mercenary group of arcana
using a backdrop of fresh corpses
from his own men to make a point.
Most of what he said can't be broadcast.
Hours later,
he escalated yet again,
saying flatly
his men would leave parliament, the city
he and Moscow
made their main prize all winter
but failed to capture.
Snazzy up that one month ago
they stopped giving us ammunition.
We are receiving
only 10% this death of a man on May 10th.
20, 23.
We are leaving the settlement of Blake
moot.
We have 2.5
kilometers
left to take out of 45 kilometers.
And then,
as if he hadn't
made his point to a country
where criticism just doesn't happen,
He accused Russia's
defense minister
of being behind the deaths
of tens of thousands.
All right. This will be the horizon.
And that difference of the dead
and the wounded
and it is tens of thousands of people.
They lie on the conscience of those
who did not give us ammunition.
And this is the Minister
of Defense, Shoigu.
And this is the chief
of the general staff
Jaroslav Prigozhin
has recently talked a lot.
But this time
it really matters
and is incredibly rare
criticism of the top and Putin's Russia.
The target of his ire
was visiting troops in the south.
Defense Minister Sergei Shoigu,
still Putin's military head,
last seen together two weeks ago.
Despite a disastrous year of war,
making criticism of him,
potentially criticism of Putin.
Today, Putin met
his Security Council
nominally to discuss annual Victory Day
Parade celebrations,
to not spoil
this fog that won't leave parliament
until one day after, Prigozhin said.
Another topic
that was bound to be on the agenda
this apparent drone
attack on the Kremlin,
which Moscow has accused Washington
of masterminding,
yet provided little evidence to support
It's all a ludicrously bad
look for the Kremlin,
no matter what's happening
behind closed doors.
Ukraine perhaps
launching a counter offensive imminently.
Seized on the baffling
display of disunity,
saying this could be a turning point
in parliament.
And Wagner was actually short of people,
not shells.
Impossible to have guessed.
In the dark meat grinder of winter here.
But a large part of Moscow's troops
would simply say
they are leaving
just as Ukraine's big push begins.
Quite what comes next
is likely also unpredictable.
But these atrocious signals
from Moscow of callous disregard
for troops
and appalling security
at the heart of government
can't be boosting Russian
frontline morale
and were unthinkable a year ago.
CNN's Nick Paton Walsh reporting
from the war zone in Ukraine.
Thanks very much.
Joining us now,
the Ukrainian ambassador
to the United States, Oksana Sakuraba.
Ambassador,
thank you so much for joining us.
As you heard,
the head of the Wagner group,
the Russian group, has made outrageous
claims before
So do you expect his mercenaries
to withdraw from, quote,
which they failed to capture
the supreme commander in chief?
Thank you, Wolf, for having me.
Look, we see the
quarrels between different war criminals
who might not be getting the ammunition
or whatever.
He is not getting from the Russian army.
But our brave defenders did not see
the stop of the of the military attack
and the aggression there.
And today,
a day after that
claim thrown from
because the Russians
have used phosphorus, ammunition
and our special forces put out,
even if video do about it.
So
you know,
they are not motivated and definitely
they do not know
what they're fighting for
because it's our land, it's our country.
And they are simply comedians
War crimes
one after
Nazis started
with the crime of aggression,
whatever this means,
whether they will be replaced
with someone or they will remain there
It doesn't matter.
Actually, we just have to keep focused on
liberating more of our territories.
And while we always
thank our friends here
for all the support we are receiving,
this is the moment to double down
and actually get the peace faster.
Do you think, Ambassador,
that this Russian infighting
that we're now seeing threatens
Vladimir Putin?
They are.
Well, you know, they have been pretty
dysfunctional.
Since the day one.
We all remember
spoke about how this is the second
largest army
and they failed miserably
on the battlefield since then.
I mean, it's very difficult for us.
The destruction
the force does is enormous there.
The cities destroyed, people killed,
but they were not able
to achieve any of their objectives.
And hopefully, with the continued support
and with the new counter-offensive,
we will be able to deny them
rights to any of our territory.
And hopefully we'll rebuild,
liberate our people.
CNN has
learned, Ambassador,
that Russia has been jamming
the gas needed for Ukraine
to operate some sophisticated U.S.
made rocket systems,
forcing Ukraine to come up with
what are called workarounds.
How concerning is that
as Ukraine
prepares
to launch this long
awaited counteroffensive
against the invading Russian troops
Well, whatever they do
desperately looking for
for some remedies, they actually should
just get out from Ukraine
and stop their war, know
and think about the justice,
because this is the main
word for what will happen
not only to Putin and everyone
who made decisions,
but also to everyone who supported
and everyone on the battlefield.
But, you know, whatever they will try.
We are ready and we will keep fighting.
We will not surrender
And our armed forces
and our brave president
have shown again and again again
that we are very creative and we will
we are very resilient
and we will bravely defend our country.
Ambassador Oksana Merkava,
thank you so much for joining us.
Good luck to you.
Good luck to all the people of Ukraine.
We really appreciate it very much.
Thank you, Wolf.
And thank you to all American people.